hey Lizzie give us the info we are dying
to know how much you've changed since
your show and movie in the early 2000s
are you going to keep that sweet 90
style or are you coming back with a
fashion upgrade well your cartoon self
look the same or will she get an upgrade
- so much has changed since we last saw
you
we're willing to bet you've got a lot to
share with the world the Lizzie McGuire
reboot has us all singing this is what
dreams are made of but just how much is
the cast of Lizzie McGuire changed since
the show originally aired in 2001 hang
out here to find out which cast member
has undergone the biggest changes watch
until the end to find out who it is
while we don't know much about the
reboot we were able to find out that the
show plans to pick up on Lizzie's 30th
birthday but who will be along for the
ride if everyone from the old cast comes
back here is what the new Lizzie McGuire
will look like LaLanne
we all knew LaLanne Vergara para as
Lizzie's bestie Miranda Sanchez on the
show many have wondered where she
disappeared to after the show ended she
spoke candidly with HuffPost about how
she dipped out of the spotlight after
Lizzie McGuire
she left Los Angeles for a while and
went on an adventure that included
joining a girl band for a couple of
years she learned how to play bass and
lays low for a while it remains to be
seen whether she will be part of the
reboot Adam Lambert fun fun Lord of the
Flies is about shipwrecked children
eating each other Gordo played by Adam
Lambert was Lizzie and Miranda zidor
Keable best friend on the show so many
fans hopes Lizzie would see him as more
than a friend but after the show Adams
stepped away from the TV cameras and
worked on getting his college degree he
now works as a developmental associate
at the Irish Art Center in New York City
but don't worry if you miss him you can
find him on social media where he is
pretty active Jake Thomas who can forget
about Lizzie's troublemaking brother
Matt McGuire while we all remember him
as the prankster kid on the show Jake
Thomas the actor who played Matt is all
grown up
Jake stayed with Disney after Lizzie
McGuire ended he went on to star in Cory
in the house back in 2007 he played the
role of Jason's stickman stickler Cory's
nemesis so what is he up to now well in
his grown-up years he appeared in a
string of dark TV shows such as Criminal
Minds and Ghost Whisperer but will he
have to revisit his childish ways for
the Lizzie reboot we'll just have to
wait and see
Ashleigh Berlitz Ashleigh Berlitz played
the relentless mean girl Kate Sanders on
the Lizzie McGuire Show but in real life
she's all about justice after the show
ended Ashleigh said goodbye to
television and got her law degree she
now practices law in California she has
a husband and a daughter when asked
about what the future holds for her
Ashleigh responded that her goal was to
work on issues related to criminal
justice reform
Clayton Snyder Clayton Snyder played the
role of Ethan Kraft Lizzie's dream guy
on the show new home the shampoo bottle
has directions right not much has
changed for Clayton in the looks
department he is still as gorgeous as
ever in his adult years
so how has he managed to stay in such
great shape well it could be due to the
fact that he has taken up water polo he
has even played on the US men's national
team but he still continues to pursue
acting which is promising maybe he'll
make an appearance on the new show as
Leslie's grown-up hunky boyfriend or
even husband Holly Todd Holly Todd was
Lizzie's mom on the show her name was
Joe McGuire and she helps Leslie learn a
lot of valuable lessons throughout the
series that may be why Holly decided to
take up teaching after the show ended
she went after what she was naturally
good at she currently teaches acting
classes in California on top of that she
is now a producer her production company
has produced films such as the Maureen
and the last champion Disney has been
pretty hush-hush about which stars are
returning to the cast of the show but we
hope Holly makes the cut even a grown-up
meets her mom every once in a while
Robert Carradine Robert Carradine played
our favorite whacky known painting dad
Sam McGuire
he was Lizzie's good-natured and goofy
father who was always
up for an adventure but Robert has
played a lot of roles since he got a
start in the 1980s he continues to act
in major and minor film and TV roles
including Quentin Tarantino's Django
Unchained it's unclear whether he will
return for the Lizzie free boots but it
seems likely given he hasn't really left
the spotlight we wonder if he will bring
his gnomes with him Hilary Duff the
actress who played the role of Lizzie
McGuire has had quite a journey since
she left the show she had a music career
for a while before going to the big
screen for a role opposite John Cusack
in the film war ink most recently she
plays the role of a single mother in the
TV series younger but right now she is
all about Lizzie she posted on her
Instagram that she has been trying to
contain her excitement for a long time
while the reboot was in the works she
wrote that she is beyond excited to be
home again back with her girl Lizzie and
into her 30s which character are you
most excited to see in the reboot tell
us in the comments hit that subscribe
button and give this video a big thumbs
up we'll see you next time on the things
thanks for watching
[Music]